yes I have Maxim with me welcome Maxim
you just finished your game in the draw
these days it's so difficult to win a
game to lose a game like how can you
explain what's happening five draws
right so far I mean yesterday I missed
an opportunity but basically an
opportunity that I didn't expect um okay
so I plays this powerful preparation
then I understand that he missed a first
move Knight F5 but later on he was
avoiding
draws and uh you know getting things
very crazy and I basically what he told
me after the game is that he missed one
move after another yeah show a little
bit use this one no just at the critical
moment I mean it went in a second
because I mean I still didn't expect to
have such such an attack so I thought uh
if he takes on A6 I take on B2 and
anyway Bishop D5 is my next move I
didn't see at all this was F5 um yeah
but actually speaking about this game I
should have posed
but but before that it was very good
game that's why for me at least um how
difficult it was to play this game for
you I mean you had to find so many
defensive moves like this Knight F5 the
only move in the position the thing is
uh here I was posing because Rook C8 is
the obvious move but I was very scared
of Rook C5 and the end I thought okay
let's let him uh is a finder remembers
move Rook C5 and play Rook C8 and well
unfortunately he played F4 because he s
that was part of his preparation that's
that's what happened because he had F4
somewhere and he s here it's good he
brend Knight F5 uh and for today it's a
bit uh shameful but why no but basically
it comes down first of all I mean the
the cons
moves were position so of course I mean
move
orderan just wanted me to to think a bit
more than I should which he managed but
so with a bishop on A7 instead of B6 I
was thinking for so much time uh to try
to figure out the difference between the
bishop and B6 first of all after Bishop
E3 which I wanted I was not sure about
Bishop G4 already Knight D2 and Castle
but of course this is just
good um for me so probably it's what I
should have gone with and
also actually what I spent a lot of time
was Knight D2 King E7 Knight F3 Bishop
B7 and here some after kn5 kn4 I was not
even sure that I'm not getting worse
because I cannot take this
Pawn this is what I was and King E8 and
yeah I mean maybe it's still Within
drawing imin but here maybe I should
have posed I I thought about Bishop C2
but I just assumed it's nothing which is
probably true but I thought it might be
um a bit of a difference compared to the
bishop on B6 and that's why I settle for
GX C5 but in the end I was just scared
of this position for like somehow you
get scared for for no reason yeah and
yeah I just thought I was for sing a
draw uh
and you know come another day of course
yeah I should have gone A4 right away um
what do you think about the sending
there was a big discussion rook and
Bishop or Knight and oh sorry rook and
Bishop or Knight and Bishop what I mean
rook and Bishop of course is better in
general I mean uh here I was getting a
bit scared about G6 I thought G6 was the
the way to to try to keep the game going
and Rook a one mhm um but of course
shouldn't be anything but some ideas
with Rook C1 with Rook D1 mhm um yeah I
wanted I wanted Knight G5 actually and
King E7 this is where I wasn't sure
maybe I yeah I want to take actually and
probably this is all thing I mean it
takes a lot to do this game with white
so I I I didn't manage but um but you
felt that it's possible I mean if I get
something it's easier to play Bishop E3
because A4 I didn't feel like I mean
first of all there's B4 but I thought
even Castle now with a rook still on A8
so I mean just a Miss on my part like I
mean probably I checked this bishop A7
long time ago but uh it was just uh
Bishop B6 is such a the automatic move
so yeah Gary kaspar was today in the
studio I mean through Zoom call and he
said that this was interesting
consequences of moves which NE nepo
chose today so he was maybe also puzzled
with the difference where
Bop so maybe Bop is move night maybe
maybe Knight D2 maybe because this is
what I spend the most time on so this
position maybe here there's uh no need
to panic uh like I did because of course
Bishop on7 is very active but my king is
safer so uh I shouldn't be
worse um so yeah I mean this might have
been the way to to try to to keep
playing a bit but uh yeah and of course
I mean the thing is you bring nepo who
is obviously in his prep so you don't
know how far so what's going on so after
while I just decided to play it safe and
well made it a bit tricky for myself but
draw is okay so you finished the day in
the office today what is the plan for
tomorrow you have a rest day finally
yeah no it's good uh I'll be looking to
prepare a bit for my for my last three
games so you know um Al then I will get
immediately a second thir day after my
game with
Richard uh so I'll have some time to
prepare I'll have some time to rest of
course and uh maybe to enjoy some tennis
uh you know in the first Park ah you
will play you mean I will try to find
people to do to do so I'm not sure like
I think Fabi was also before the
tournament I was not very successful but
uh in finding Partners but maybe maybe
this time around it will work out okay
good luck with that Maxum as well with
with your games thank you and and we go
back to the studio thank you Anastasia
mvl some advice Ray Ray Robson is ready
willing and able he's a very good tennis
partner so uh check in with Ray Ray uh